bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france la signature d'une
déclaration commune ce jour une nouvelle
étape pour vous pour entériner un peu
plus le cessez-le-feu
je crois en effet que à partir du moment
où la russie a été un acteur principal
dans la médiation dans la signature de
l'accord la russie se devait de de
continuer ses efforts pour apaiser
complètement la région et ceci passe
évidemment par des accords de
développement économique de
développement des infrastructures la
construction de la route entre ces
pannes à capter et javan une deuxième
route qui double le corridor de latchine
probablement aussi la question de la
communication entre le nakhitchevan et
l'azerbaïdjan est donc un vrai programme
de développement auquel sans doute
d'ailleurs la communauté internationale
sera invité à participer mais il ya sans
doute d'autres choses qui n'apparaissent
pas dans la déclaration commune qui ont
été discutées et qui sont évidemment
très importante le d'abord la question
du statut du haut karabakh puisque
chacun sait que l'accord du 10 novembre
ne comporte aucune disposition sur ce
statut est sans aucun doute les trois en
ont parlé et notamment la question des
garanties à donner aux populations
arméniennes la question des lieux saints
arméniens des monastères tout ça tout
cela sans doute était été abordés et
bien sûr et il ya peut-être encore une
question qui a été traité mais qu'il ne
figurera pas dans les communiqués qui a
été traitée mezzo voce c'est la question
de la turquie puisque chacun sait aussi
que les turcs ne figure pas dans
l'accord du 10 novembre qu'ils sont très
demandeurs de présence sur le terrain
que les discussions sont allées en train
sur cette question que les turcs ont
obtenu de participer à la station de
contrôle radio électronique qui sera
installée en territoire
l'azerbaïdjanais et qu'ils ont tenu
aussi de participer à l'effort de
déminage des zones récupéré par les
azerbaïdjanaises donc en dehors de la
déclaration qui elle même est centré
plus sur les questions de développement
il y as d'autres questions qui ont sans
doute été traité et nous n'en
connaissons pas les résultats
alors notamment peut-être la question
majeure et non des moindres à nos
statuts du nagorny karabach qui pourrait
intervenir qu'en cette question une
situation qui ne saurait être abordé
trop tôt et bien en fait pour les
azerbaïdjanais n'y a pas de question
c'est à dire que pour eux le le nagorny
karabakh faisant partie du territoire
azerbaïdjanais
il ne relève pas d'un statut particulier
qui serait à gré au niveau international
et a créé avec l'arménie mais ça c'est
au niveau déclaratoire defacto je pense
que le médiateur russe s'efforcera
d'obtenir un minimum de garanties pour
les populations arméniennes la
population arménienne justement qui
craint de son côté de nouvelles
concessions de nikol pashinian il y aura
forcément selon vous je crois que la
corse suffit à lui-même
dans cet accord il y à l'essentiel début
de guerre de l'azerbaïdjan sert la
récupération du territoire
azerbaïdjanais et l'absence de vin et la
récupération d'une liberté de manoeuvre
total sur le le statut à supposer qu'il
y ait un statut en tout cas aussi à
accorder aux citoyens aux citoyens donc
désormais azerbaïdjanais du nagorny part
du karabakh mais qui sont arméniens en
fait
tweed de l'aide humanitaire c'est
également l'un des sujets
qui devaient être abordées extrêmement
important ce sera ma dernière question
l'aide humanitaire c'est un c'est
toujours une des questions les gens les
moins difficiles à régler comme vous le
savez par exemple la france a envoyé
avec l'accord des autorités russes des
avions cargos pour soulager les
populations arméniennes
la question se pose en termes de des
deux à la réinstallation éventuellement
des azerbaïdjanais mais ça ce sera
plutôt une question azerbaïdjanaise et
turque
et en ce qui concerne le le haut
karabagh la reconstruction dépendra en
fait de des désaccords qui seront fur et
à mesure signée mais l'aide humanitaire
ne devrait pas poser de problème
important dans la rue dans la région
enfin chacun à ceux dans les siens si je
puis dire merci beaucoup jean de
gliniasty est directeur de recherche à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques d'avoir été avec nous